una ciudad estratégica en el rumbo de la
guerra en Ucrania su ubicación
privilegiada en la orilla del río nieper
cerca de la desembocadura del mar Negro
Explica el júbilo de las tropas
ucranianas tras retomar la ciudad gerson
fue ocupada por Rusia pocos días después
del inicio de la invasión en febrero de
este año su cercanía la Península de
crimea anexada por Vladimir Putin en
2014 favoreció a las tropas rusas en su
avance hacia el centro y norte de
Ucrania la industrializada urbe que
contaba con 280.000 habitantes antes de
la ocupación fue evacuada en días
recientes por las autoridades locales
prorusas ante el avance del ejército
ucraniano cerca de 70.000 personas
fueron desplazadas a comienzos de
noviembre estas imágenes muestran la
desolación
Pero cuál será el nuevo rumbo de la
guerra con gerson de vuelta en manos
ucranianas Rusia recibe su tercer gran
golpe en estos nueve meses de guerra
luego el repliegue en kiev y hardkif la
huida de gerson única capital de
provincia que estuvo bajo control ruso
no es una simple derrota más para Putin
según La retórica de Moscú gersor hace
parte del territorio de la federación
rusa desde octubre lo que puede alentar
a Ucrania a recuperar otras regiones del
Sur que también Fueron anexadas por
Rusia como zaporiya e incluso crimea
donde el suministro de agua potable y de
elementos básicos podría estar en riesgo
ya que ahora solo se conecta Rusia
continental por el puente de kerch
sin embargo las autoridades rusas
confían en que el repliegue en gerson no
cambia el rumbo de lo que bautizaron
operación militar especial el portavoz
del Ministerio de defensa de Rusia Igor
con priorizó la seguridad de sus tropas
y del equipamiento militar durante La
retirada
expertos señalan que la caída de gerson
demuestra la debilidad de Rusia incluso
para defender sus bastiones una
debilidad que podría aumentar en los
próximos días en las zonas aledañas de
gerson con un ejército ucraniano
envalentonado